so i was uh sitting in a cafe this
morning thinking about today's show and
making some notes and reading some stuff
and i overheard a conversation as as i
do
as i i like to do this is this is one of
the things that uh the animal
behaviorist and me enjoys being able to
do and uh frankly it requires anonymity
and so it's become a little bit less
easy to do the more of this uh that we
we put out into the world but in this
case
eavesdropping
yeah um often often i will then engage
with the people in this case i didn't
have the opportunity um but it was two
men
a young man and a man that could have
been his father although i think i think
he wasn't
at breakfast and
i heard uh i i heard them say listen
listen to what they're saying they're
saying this new variant is brand new so
get vaccinated with the vaccines that
don't work very well in the previous new
variant
and this guy continues he says it makes
no sense at all no sense and yet most
people seem to be buying it
and then and i didn't actually catch
which of the two guys said that but then
the younger man says in the context of
this little piece of the conversation he
says my friends all sound the way that i
do on this
meaning you know this the messaging is
making no sense but then i look around
he says and i know that almost everyone
else doesn't see it
and i'm hearing this and i think they
weren't actually an earshot of anyone
else in the restaurant and they sort of
were looking around the restaurant when
when they said that
but
my sense my sense
is actually that those conversations
like the one i overheard are happening
far more frequently than the people who
are having them believe and that that is
that is intentional that is sort of
necessary that we believe that we are a
tiny minority and that we stay
we stay in our in our little pockets
without any connection to one another
and that we and that we believe that
everyone else is going along with
something even if we can see uh that you
know pick your pick your narrative
metaphor the emperor has no clothes or
when you you know look at the man behind
the curtain he's not what you thought
you know any any of these things which
are which are true
plato's cave um yeah exactly um and i
think i think there is the potential for
hope to be found in
the
recognition i think
that
there are actually many many more people
who are awake at least at some level
then then
mainstream messaging would have us
believe
all right a couple
couple things i'm i'm seeing the same
phenomenon a lot of people are waking up
um
sarah silverman had a moment yesterday
really yeah which was one people did not
expect yeah um
i think a number of things are happening
at once one the rate at which people
are waking up is high and that's very
good on the other hand something else is
accelerating maybe because people are
waking up so quickly
so part of the game here has been to
leave
a mind so your mind was built by
selection for
a world in which you actually walk
around and you sort of do an
unscientific census of the world that
gives you know if um somebody has a
freak accident in front of you that may
not tell you anything if it happens
three times in a week you may think well
what's
what's causing this maybe nothing is it
can be random but sometimes it isn't but
anyway the point is the mind
is under normal circumstances very good
at getting a sense
for whether something is up
and whether something is up
you know socially speaking when you
actually have contact with you know a
billion people via some social media
platform
that
thing
would trigger you to recognize that hey
we're not all on board with the same
narrative except that the platforms are
throwing people off who disagree those
people who are still on who disagree are
demonized they are portrayed as if
they've lost the plot etc all of these
processes and what it does is it games
the mind so that the mind becomes very
comfortable with things and so this
leaves you
you and i know for example from our
larger than
common
social circle we
we have a lot of people in contact with
us now
large fraction of those people
have very serious private doubts many of
which have not been publicly
acknowledged many serious what
uh serious private what doubts doubts
okay i thought you said debts
oh i don't know anything about it
it's impolite to talk about
but many many people with whom we are in
contact have um doubts that they are
keeping to themselves but they will
share with us for instance right and
many of them frank doubts about the
public messaging about the
um safe and effective messaging and
about all the rest right they have
doubts about these things that have in
many cases some cases have not governed
their behavior
and in some cases have governed their
behavior and they're now wondering what
to do in a world of mandates that they
may not qualify uh to
um
to get the check mark from
and in any case
we get a very bad idea of how common
this
these doubts are
and the
arms race to keep us in the dark about
how common our perspective is is
ratcheting up rather precipitously
we of course are stuck in a predicament
with something like australia where yes
it's true we're not in australia we're
not positioned to know directly on the
other hand you and i know two people who
have fled australia
because they believe that there is a
very powerful force that will not be
transient that is engaging in
authoritarianism of an egregious kind
furthermore
um
we do live in portland and we have lived
in portland for a little over three
years at this point so we were here
during the summer of 2020 into the fall
of 2020 and
in some cases saw directly um some you
know the protests that regularly turned
into riots every night for something
like 100 more than 100 consecutive
nights
and the damage to downtown and the
enduring damage and the just wasteland
that so much of
frankly a lot of east portland has
become
and and yet it's not everywhere even
then even at the worst time of it it
wasn't everywhere and it wasn't all the
time it was actually fairly predictable
when and where it was and portland is
tiny compared to australia and so people
could plausibly grant it i don't think
they were actually doing honest
journalism but people could plausibly
come into portland during the height of
the reliably nightly riots and stand in
the middle of a beautiful square on in
the middle of the day and say i don't
see an ent for here therefore it's not
real and
that story was bought right so if that
can happen in portland which is frankly
very small and anyone who was interested
could have asked almost any resident of
portland where would i go to see these
alleged you know these alleged riots and
they would have been pointed to the
right place and they would have seen it
uh in australia it's you know it's far
bigger it's still looser you know there
are there are a couple of these
of these places where people are now um
being funneled but by and large the
argument that you're not here you don't
know what's going on is is a it's a
faint you know fbi nt it's a faint
because
there are a lot of people who live in
australia who won't be directly seeing
what is happening in other parts of
australia well there's that and there is
also the problem that the incentives
surrounding acknowledging what is taking
place mean that if anybody who is in
australia can pull rank on anybody who
isn't in australia then what you get is
an effective veto over a
yes imprecise but nonetheless accurate
perception something has gone wrong in
australia which is now engaged in
behavior that is not you know
i mean so we have
internment camps okay we have internment
camps in which you cannot leave for a
period of time but then you go home okay
that's not exact it's not manzanar right
but it is something
and you know we have a right to think
about it and it's an it's another form
of stay in your laneism which you know
we have if we have previously argued
against all forms of stay in your loan
lane-ism uh because the lane that may be
actually legitimately described by an
historical discipline that really did
constrain certain kinds of inquiry that
involved certain kinds of methods that
if you weren't familiar with you might
not know how to assess claims of truth
in that discipline right
that said the standard way to acquire
that knowledge which would allow you to
assess claims within that discipline
because they are corruptable they have
become corrupt and therefore requiring
that you have followed the standard way
to acquire knowledge
is a way to to accelerate the corruption
and that is true even in places where
there might actually have been a lane
historically that was legitimate but you
know geographical stay in your laneism i
live on you know basically i live in
this
this quadrant of the planet
it's not quite a quadrant but you know i
live on this continent and therefore i
know what's going on here and you don't
well that's patent [ __ ] yeah that's
not it's a little bit like sarah palin
um having lots of foreign policy
experience by virtue of you know russia
being
just over the straight i thought you and
that was that was easy for you know half
of the country including us time to
laugh at like oh for god's sake you know
but
now now it's roughly the same half of
the country just buying these kinds of
absurd arguments right well in a sense i
mean
you and i have bristled it uh stay in
your lane since the first time we heard
it because of course it is a territorial
argument and
uh it is it is used to silence that
which is uh inconvenient etc um but the
argument you just make makes me
makes me realize that effectively lane
as it's being used in this case
are a kind of blinders and the idea is
you are to blind yourself
to that which is outside of your lane
and so my sense is that we actually have
um what was the thing we talked about a
number of streams ago we talked about
the uh the obligation
to disagree
oh yes uh which um gosh i'm gonna
mispronounce his name again richard
rearson i think on his on his podcast
revealed that um he's a he's a both a
former marine and i believe a a
commercial pilot who said that in
aviation there is a obligation
i don't have the framing right i can't
remember exactly the phrase but an
obligation to disagree
obligation to challenge not not
uh a tolerance for challenge but an
obligation an obligation to challenge
and so i think um
basically my feeling is um not only
should we reject this stay in your
laneism but we should found stay out of
your lane ism
all right that you have an obligation to
get out of your lane and see what is
adjacent because frankly or you're
living in a i wouldn't say stay out of
your land say get out of your lane so
you know you you also get to live in
whatever domain you you
feel that you legitimately have
expertise in you don't want to you don't
want to throw out and get out of your
lane is better yeah you're right stay
out of your lane is linguistically more
fun but get out of your lane is right
but anyway i mean at some level look
this is
i don't know i'm having the sense that
something is going on this week and it
may be that it's just crossed a
threshold for me this week and it's not
really this week on the other hand it
may be that there's something to it and
increasingly it's like look either
you know yes our enemies will make hay
of this but either we've just lost the
plot and we don't understand the first
thing and i think yeah
and
i can effectively prove that short of
something amazing like uh you know
schizophrenia in which uh none of what
we think is evidence is actually even
external to our minds but short of that
shooting all of the people we are
interacting with right exactly but short
of something really exotic like that you
can effectively prove this isn't true it
doesn't mean that we know what is going
on but it means that you can detect the
anomalies they're everywhere and the
thing about your freaking lane
is your lane allows them to construct a
potemkin reality in front of you and our
basic point to those with whom we
disagree is
we see the potemkin reality also but if
you stand over there you'll see that
it's a set right yeah you're being led
to understand a particular picture you
have dots put in front of you and you're
thinking that you're clever for collect
connecting them and the point is it
doesn't add up unless you do stay in
your lane yeah and i think i mean
actually there's sort of there's like
little breadcrumbs dribbled for people i
suspect in which people are allowed to
feel clever for discovering little
anomalies or you know things that don't
quite fit and then
and then they think they've gone all the
way right and you know this this one
just this this whole
again the metaphors are endless but you
know for the moment i just call it a
house of cards you can't you can't take
one card off and go like now you can't
take one card off the top and say now
that thing is built on a stable
foundation that's not how foundation
works right and in fact i mean here's
one i had a little fun this week i put
up a poll on uh on twitter
you know obviously polls on twitter
aren't scientific because
you know people who follow me and
therefore see it are not a random sample
although i asked people to distribute it
to places that wouldn't
wouldn't be reached it's a you know it's
it's a put up your finger and see which
way the wind is blowing in this very you
know in in an admittedly local yes it's
a straw poll yeah and the point is a
close answer wouldn't tell you anything
but a
an answer that's wildly off in one
direction does and anyway i asked people
to
rate what they thought the level of
pharma corruption of
academia
government and
media was
with respect to covid relative to
average
your average disease
you know and it was like it's negligible
it's below average
it's about average it's above average
and the answer was
84 percent of people thought it was
above average now here's my point above
average doesn't mean anything it doesn't
mean it's tolerable or intolerable or
anything but
our public narrative is as if there is
no corruption here right whereas people
privately talking about the corruption
that at least has been demonstrated to
exist in all previous right effects you
know attempts to to deal with public
health with pharmaceuticals um is
immediately called a conspiracy theory
as opposed to actually the burden of
proof that this isn't happening is on
you the default hypothesis here the null
hypothesis is that this is business as
usual and that the pharmaceutical
companies are not actually engaged in
trying to to to heal people so that they
don't so they no longer need the
products right like that's the null
hypothesis not the other way around
right in fact um you know
certain things like we know that pharma
routinely knocks drugs that work out of
the
standard of care in favor of drugs that
are under patent right so when a drug
goes out of patent there's a question
about you know the pattern of discovery
of something new that's claimed to be
even better is unnatural right if that's
normal
then why do we assume it plays no role
in the claims by pharma in this case
that x y and z doesn't work and so
anyway just even a baseline assumption
that hey
there's a whole
slew of evidence people become expert in
pharma corruption it's in fact a very
fascinating and complex phenomenon you
can uh read rfk
jr's book for example you can read ben
goldacre right pharma corruption is a
powerful powerful force and it does
involve adjusting people's view of
things and um
until you've at least figured out what
baseline is and at least allowed that
baseline might continue into covid you
don't you're not even in a position to
have this discussion
[Music]